WHO ARE HERE ON TIME AND TO THE
DEMOCRATIC MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE WHO ARE HERE ON TIME.
THE BY CUSTOM WE ARE WAITING ON
ONE REPUBLICAN MEMBER BEFORE WE
CAN START AS A SUBCOMMITTEE.
THE CUSTOM NOT A ROLE WHICH
MEANS IN ABOUT TWO MINUTES WE'RE
GONNA START ANYWAY
. FOR THE
AUDIENCE THAT MISTER MAIENSCHEIN
IS THE DEMOCRAT WE ARE STILL
WAITING FOR AN ACTUAL REPUBLICAN.
NO FORMER REPUBLICANS MR HELL
[inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
WELCOME TO AND THE JUNE
NINETEENTH ASSEMBLY
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE HEARING
MAY OF NINETEEN BILLS TO
CONSIDER THIS MORNING -- AND WE
ARE GOING TO GO QUICKLY THROUGH
THIS MR HELL IF YOU LIKE TO
PRESENT.
WE'RE STARTING I'M SORRY AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE NOTING THE ABSENCE
OF A QUORUM MR HILL HAS SB TWO
TWENTY WHICH ENJOY THE DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION SOON AS WE GET A
QUORUM HERE.
STRENGTHEN SECURITY REQUIREMENTS
OF FIREARMS RETAILERS TO HELP
PREVENT FIRE IN THEFT AND EVICT
I'D IDENTICAL BILL IS BEFORE
SIXTY FOUR WAS APPROVED BY THIS
COMMITTEE IN.
TWENTY SEVENTEEN THE BILL
PROVIDES SEVERAL COMPLIANCE
OPTIONS FOR FIREARMS DEALERS AND
WILL HAVE A VERY MINOR PHYSICAL
IMPACTS I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
RIVAL COLLEAGUES.
THANK YOU WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
ENGINE ALL ME ASSURE THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE -- WE DO
NOT HAVE A POSITION AT THIS TIME
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
ESTIMATES MINOR COSTS.
THANK YOU.
I SEE NO QUESTIONS WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE RESPECTFULLY AS
RIVAL COLLEGE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MANAGER SOON AS WE GET A
QUORUM WILL TAKE THAT UP THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
MR HERTZBERG SENATOR HERTZBERG --
SB THIRTY SIX IS ON CONSENT I'M
ASSUMING YOU'RE NOT PULLING THAT%
OFF BUT YOU'LL PRESENT ON SB ONE
NINETY TWO AND ENJOY IT I DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION.
SOON AS WE GET A QUORUM.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
IN THIS LEGISLATURE EVERY YEAR
WE PASSED THOUSANDS OF NEW LAWS.
IN SO THIS IS AN EFFORT TO TAKE
ONE OFF THE BOOKS ONE THAT WAS
WRITTEN IN EIGHTEEN SEVENTY TWO
DESIGNED. TO GO AFTER RUN AWAY
SLAVES.
IT MAKES IT A CRIME AND FINE FOR
YOU FAILURE TO JOIN A POSSE.
AND SO WE'RE TAKING IT OFF THE
BOOKS THIS IDEA CAME FROM --
NUMBER OF IN TERMS OF MY OFFICES
WE SCRUBBED ALL TWENTY NINE
CODES OF THE STATE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND TO THOSE GOOD
SAMARITANS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THEY'RE MORE THAN
ANOTHER DOZEN OTHER STATUTES.
THAT ARE IN FORM THE IDEA OF
PEOPLE HELP AND LAW ENFORCEMENT
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU ARE THERE SPEAKERS IN
SUPPORT.
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE --
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE INDICATES
MINOR COSTS.
YEAH I I LOST MY HORSE I'M SO
GLAD YOU HAVE THAT.
THE FOUR WE MOVE I AM GOING --
TO ASK MA'AM SECRETARY TO PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL [inaudible]
GONZALEZ [inaudible]
BIGELOW.
BLOOM.
BONTA BROUGH.
CALDERON CARRILLO [inaudible]
CHAO [inaudible]
DEEP.
FRIEDMAN YOUR PHONE.
GABRIEL.
GARCIA MAIENSCHEIN.
OBERNOLTE PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK
HERE RIVAS -- HERE.
BOTH.
THANK YOU.
MR Là HAS QUESTION.
QUESTION.
THANK YOU MISTER HERTZBERG AYE I
APPRECIATE YOUR WANTED TO TAKE
ANOTHER LAW OFF THE BOOKS
ACTUALLY.
I'M GOOD WITH A LOT OF THOSE ARE
SILLY LAWS THAT EXIST.
THERE'S ONE IN THE COUNTY MADERA
THE STILL EXIST FROM.
EIGHTEEN NINETY THREE YOU CAN'T
GET SHOT.
A WAGON OR A HORSE TO THE TREE
IN THE COUNTY PARK STILL EXIST
TODAY.
WHEN I BROWN MARSHALL WAS?
KERRY IN THE LOCAL PARADE DOWN
THE STREETS OF MADERA.
THE HITCH THE WAGON TO THE THREE
I SHARE OF NEW THE LAW AND CITED
THE GRAND MARSHAL.
FUNNY THING THAT HAPPENED NOT.
BUT A FEW COUPLE OF YEARS AGO.
VOTER KNOWN THAT I WOULD ADDED
TO THIS BILL THAT WOULD HAVE
BEEN MOST HELPFUL BUT TODAY I I
RECOGNIZE.
THAT YEAH IN YOUR PRESENTATION
THAT THIS WAS DESIGNED BASICALLY
TO GO AFTER SLAYS BUT IT WASN'T
JUST HIS WAS IT.
IT WAS TO GO AFTER MANY
DIFFERENT ASPECTS OF LAW --
BREAKERS WHO WERE OCCURRING.
SUCH AS PEOPLE WHO STOLE FROM
PEOPLE FORCES CATTLE SHE ALL
KINDS OF THINGS SO THE PURPOSE
OF IT.
IS SOMEWHAT -- ADEQUATE IN AN
OUTDATED BUT NONE THE LESS THAT
SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION HAS TAKEN
THE POSITION OF OPPOSITION CAN
YOU EXPLAIN TO THIS BODY.
WHY THE SHARE SOME SO?
I DON'T KNOW I I YOU KNOW I
TALKED WE TALKED TO HIM.
AND IT'S YOU KNOW YEAH WE HAD A
DOZEN OR SO LAWS AND YOU ALWAYS
FIND PEOPLE THAT OPPOSE
EVERYTHING WE SEE GOVERNOR'S DO
THIS OVER THE YEARS.
LAST TIME WE COULD FIND THIS
CASE WAS USED WAS IN NINETEEN
THIRTY FIVE AND WE THINK THAT.
YOU KNOW THERE ARE CERTAINLY A
SERIES OF STATUTES I CAN SEND
THEM TO YOUR OFFICE THAT --
LEAVE THE HOSE OBLIGATIONS BUT
THIS MAKES IT A CRIME. TO
FAILURE TO JOIN A POSSE AT SOME
POINT IT GETS A LITTLE
RIDICULOUS AYE AYE AYE WE TALKED
TO IN THEIR IDEAS THAT'S JUST A
TOOL OF THE BOOKS AND THEY WANT
TO KEEP IT AND I THINK THE WRONG.
THE BILL THANK YOU HAVE A MOTION
BY DOCTOR PARK WE HAVE A SECOND
BY MISS CARILLO.
WITH THAT WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE THANK YOU.
THEY ARE VOTE THAT GETS OUT ON
IN A ROLL CALL WITH MISTER
BIGELOW NOT VOTING.
THANK YOU.
I'LL TAKE A MOTION NOW ON SB TWO
TWENTY BY MISTER HILL SO MOVED
HAVE A MOTION RIGHT AFTER QUIRK
A SECOND BY MISS CARILLO AND
THAT IS ON HOLD UNTIL WE GET A
FEW MORE DEMOCRATS HERE.
MISTER WIENER.
MISTER WEINER IS PRESENT SB
THIRTY ENJOYS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION.
I MOTIONS RIO IN A SECOND BY
DOCTOR QUIRK.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR -- BRIEFLY
THIS BILL WILL AND
DISCRIMINATION AGAINST --
OPPOSITE SEX COUPLES IN DOMESTIC
PARTNER REGISTRY.
ARE CURRENTLY ON THE ONLY PEOPLE
WHO CAN REGISTER AS DOMESTIC
PARTNERS OF SAME SEX COUPLES AND
PEOPLE OVER THE AGE OF SIXTY TWO
FOR SOCIAL SECURITY REASONS --
IT IS THAT IT'S DISCRIMINATION
NEEDS AND THIS WILL ALLOW ANYONE.
TO DO IT -- THIS BILL IN THE
SENATE WAS KEYED AS A TAX -- WE
HAVE MADE AMENDMENTS TO IT IS NO
LONGER KEY AS A TAX AND SO I
JUST WANTED TO POINT THAT OUT
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK -- FOR
NINE MISTER GREEN.
THAT'S OKAY HOLD ON JUST A
SECOND -- SUPPORTERS.
THOSE IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
THE SECRETARY OF STATE ESTIMATES
THE ANNUAL NUMBER OF RUSSIAN
DOMESTIC PARTNER TRANSACTIONS
MAY INCREASE SUBSTANTIALLY WHICH
MAY RESULT IN THE NEED FOR
APPROXIMATELY NINETY FOUR
THOUSAND GENERAL FUND AND ONE
YOU PERMANENT POSITION TO
ACCOMPLISH THIS WORKLOAD.
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
HUMAN RESOURCES IS CURRENTLY
EVALUATING THE IMPACTS OF THIS
BILL WILL UNKNOWN AT THIS TIME
THIS BILL COULD RESULT IN
ONGOING COST ASSOCIATE WITH
BENEFITS FOR STATE EMPLOYEES
REGISTERING AS DOMESTIC PARTNERS.
A ONE TIME COST UPDATE FORMS AND
INSTRUCTIONS FOR STATE EMPLOYEES
ADDITIONALLY DEPENDING ON THE
NUMBER SINGLE TAX FILERS THAT
ENTERED DOMESTIC PARTNERSHIPS
AND ALSO FILE THEIR TAXES
JOINTLY THIS BILL COULD HAVE A
NEGATIVE IMPACT ON CALIFORNIA'S
INCOME TAX REVENUE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
TOUCH QUIRK YES A COULD YOU ADD
MUSIC CO AUTHOR.
I'D BE HONORED THANK YOU
[inaudible]
WITH THAT.
AT A TO CLOSE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
AS SOON AS WE GET -- TWO MORE
DEMOCRATS HERE WILL GO AHEAD AND
TAKE THAT UP [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I DON'T SEE MISS MITCHELL.
SO I'VE SENT [inaudible]
RIGHT YES.
MADAM CHAIR YOU HAVE AC A
FOURTEEN THIS HAS BEEN A TO PASS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU CHAIR
MEMBERS AT A FOURTEEN RESOLUTION
THE ASSN VOTERS WITH THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA SHOULD
ENSURE ALL WORKERS WHO PERFORM
SUPPORT SERVICES AT THE UC.
ARE FOR THE SAME EQUAL OP
EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITY STANDARDS
AS YOU SEE EMPLOYEES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
[inaudible]
SECOND.
I WITNESSES HURTING A VERY SHORT
PRESENTATION [inaudible]
MEMBERS.
GOOD MORNING MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE CATHERINE LIVE ORDER
PRESIDENT OF APPS ME THIRTY TWO
NINETY NINE THE PEOPLE WERE
TALKING ABOUT AN ACA FOURTEEN OR
CLEANING TOILETS BED PANS.
PICKING UP TRASH THE COOKING THE
FOOD MAINTAINING THE BUILDINGS
SUPPORTING THE DOCTORS NURSES
FACULTY AND STUDENTS.
I'D LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT A FEW
POINTS ON THE ISSUE OF MONEY.
FIRST OF THE ACA APPLIES AT THE
EXPIRATION OR RENEWAL OF
EXISTING CONTRACTS WHICH
CURRENTLY ALL HAVE VARYING IN
TERMS RANGING FROM THREE TO TEN
YEARS.
AS A RESULT THERE IS A BUILT IN
PHASE IN PERIOD OF UP TO TEN
YEARS.
SECONDS NOTHING IN THE ACA
REQUIRES THE USE YOU TO HIRE THE
SAME NUMBER OF EMPLOYEES OR ANY
SPECIFIC INDIVIDUAL WORKER.
THIRD WE AGREE WITH THE
COMMITTEES ANALYSIS THAT IN
ADDITION TO THE EXCEPTIONS FOR
EMERGENCY NEEDS.
A BROAD EXEMPTION FOR PER DIEM
UNIVERSITY EMPLOYEES IS DRAFTED
BROADLY ENOUGH TO PROVIDE YOU
SEE FLEXIBILITY TO ADDRESS ANY
ADDITIONAL SHORT TERM TEMPORARY
STAFFING NEEDS.
INCLUDING IN THE MEDICAL CENTERS.
FINALLY THE STATE AUDITOR
REVIEWED YOU SEE PRESIDENT'S
ASSERTION THAT THE UC SYSTEM
WIDE PROCUREMENT PROGRAM IN.
TWENTY FIFTEEN TO SIXTEEN HAD
PRODUCED TWO HUNDRED SIXTY NINE
MILLION DOLLARS IN PROCUREMENT
BENEFITS.
A TERM USED TO REFER TO COST
REDUCTIONS OR AVOIDANCE
INCENTIVES OR REVENUE HOWEVER
THE STATE AUDITOR FOUNDER THAT
UC LACKED ADEQUATE SUPPORT TO
SUBSTANTIATE NINE OF THE TEN
ESTIMATE ESTIMATED BENEFITS
REVIEWED.
BECAUSE NEITHER THE GOVERNOR NOR
THE LEGISLATURE HAVE THE POWER
TO ENSURE SUPPORT SERVICES
WORKERS ARE TREATED EQUALLY I
ASK YOU TO CONSIDER PLACING THIS
ON THE BALLOT FOR YOUR VOTERS TO
DECIDE THANK YOU [inaudible]
NEXT WITNESS.
MY NAME IS UP THANK YOU MY NAME
IS CLAIRE PER PROGRAM HERE JUST
TO ANSWER ANY POTENTIAL
QUESTIONS THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
OF THOSE IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
PLEASE YOUR NAME AND NUMBER
ORGANIZATION.
THEY GIVE US SURE MEMBERS MITCH
SNIDER WITH THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION ALSO IN SUPPORT.
AND DR ROBERT WITH THE
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER IN SUPPORT.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION
.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS JASON MURPHY ON BEHALF
OF THE UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA --
WE HEAR TODAY IN STRONG
OPPOSITION TO A CA -- FOURTEEN
TO STICK TO THE FISCAL MATTERS I
WOULD POINT OUT THE UNIVERSITIES
FISCAL ESTIMATE IS A HUNDRED
SEVENTY TWO POINT SIX MILLION
DOLLARS AS A RESULT OF THE
PROHIBITIONS ON CONTRACTING OUT
CONTAINED.
IN A CA.
FOURTEEN THIS -- THIS IS SOME IS
MADE UP PRIMARILY OF THE BOTH
WAGE AND BENEFIT PREMIUMS WE
BELIEVE WE WOULD HAVE TO PAY OR
COVER IN ORDER BRING ALL THE
WORK THAT'S BEING DONE BY
CONTACT STAFF.
IN HOUSE I KNOW THE ANALYSIS
POINTS OUT THAT IT'S POSSIBLE
THAT -- SOME THIS WORK BE TAKEN
ON BY EXISTING EMPLOYEES BUT I
WOULD TELL YOU THAT -- HE'LL
BOTH OUR COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
AGREEMENTS AND JUST GENERAL
PRACTICES.
TYPICALLY PRECLUDE YOU FROM JUST
HEAPING MORTICIAN WORK ON TOP OF
THOSE THAT ARE ALREADY.
WORKING FOR THE UNIVERSITY SO WE
DO NOT BELIEVE THAT THERE'S
SAVINGS TO BE FOUND THERE AT ALL.
IN ADDITION TO THE WAGE PREMIUMS
A BENEFIT PREVIEWS I'VE
DISCUSSED WE DO ALSO EXPECT THAT
THERE WILL BE ADDITIONAL
EQUIPMENT THAT THE UNIVERSITY
WOULD HAVE TO TO PROCURE IN AND
BRING IN HOUSES RESULT OF THIS
WE DO PCA CONTRACT OUT IN CASES
WHERE WE HAVE A NEED FOR
SPECIALIZED.
EQUIPMENT AND SO FORTH WE ALSO
BELIEVE THAT WE HAVE TO HIRE
ADDITIONAL SUPERVISORIAL STAFF
TO SUPERVISE THESE NEW EMPLOYEES
THAT WOULD BE BROUGHT ON BOARD.
PURSUANT TO THE BILL AS WELL AS
HAVE IMPACTS ON THE HEALTH AND
CLINICAL SIDE WHEREBY WE WOULD
HAVE REVENUE LOSSES IN
ADDITIONAL COSTS.
AS A RESULT OF HAVING -- TO THE
FOR THE FOR OR REMOVE PATIENTS
MOVE THE MONTH OTHER FACILITIES
AS WELL AS PERHAPS CANCEL --
PROCEDURES AND THE LIKE AS A
RESULT OF NOT HAVING SUFFICIENT
STAFFING SO I DO HAVE A
COLLEAGUE HERE WITH ME TODAY
FROM THE HEALTH SIDE LIKE THE
TURNED OVER HER AT THIS POINT.
TO SHARE HER VIEWS.
GOOD MORNING CHEN MEMBERS MY
NAME IS ANGELA GILYARD AND I
REPRESENT THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA HEALTH SYSTEM I AM
THE DIRECTOR STATE HEALTH POLICY.
AND I JUST HAVE A BRIEF
STATEMENT THAT -- YOU SEE USES
CONTRACT WORKERS ONLY WHEN
NECESSARY TO FILL VACANCIES OR
WHEN OUR EMPLOYEES ARE OUT
BECAUSE OF BECAUSE THEY ARE ON
FAMILY MEDICAL LEAVE -- AT THE
UC DAVIS CENTER FOR EXAMPLE IF
YOU SEE GIVES HEALTH CENTER AND
CAMPUS.
THERE WERE TWENTY THREE HUNDRED
EMPLOYEES THAT HAVE TAKEN FMLA
FROM JANUARY ONE TO LAST MONDAY.
CONTRACT OR CONTINGENCY HALF
WORKERS HAVE BEEN USED TO FILL
SOME OF THESE TEMPORARY GAPS
WHEN THE EMPLOYEES RETURN THEIR
JOBS ARE WAITING.
HOWEVER A CA FOURTEEN WITH DEAN
THE TEMPORARY WORKERS AS
EMPLOYEES AFTER ONLY TEN DAYS SO
THEORETICALLY AT UC DAVIS FOR
EXAMPLE BETWEEN JANUARY ONE AND
NOW -- WE WOULD HAVE ADDED UP TO
TWENTY THREE HUNDRED NEW
EMPLOYEES AND AS YOU CAN SEE
THIS POLICY GETS EXPENSIVE AND
BECOMES IMPRACTICAL AND
UNWORKABLE OVER TIME.
I THERE IS A MYTH THAT USE HE
DOESN'T WANT TO FILL ITS VACANT
POSITIONS HOWEVER YOU SEE HAS A
RECRUITMENT AND SCREENING
PROCESS TO FILL VACANT POSITIONS
BUT MANY POSITIONS.
AT ALL LEVELS ARE VERY DIFFICULT
TO FILL. FOR EXAMPLE AGAIN AT UC
DAVIS AT THE HOSPITAL AT THE
MEDICAL CENTER AND AT THE CAMPUS
THERE FOURTEEN HUNDRED OPEN
POSITIONS.
BETWEEN THE MAIN CAMPUS AND
MEDICAL CENTERS FOR AN OVERALL
VACANCY RATE OF ABOUT 11% JUST
AT THAT ONE CAMPUS.
THIS WILL VARY FROM CAMPUS TO
CAMPUS.
BUT THE CONTRACT USERS CONTRACT
WORKERS ARE USED TO FILL SOME OF
THESE GAPS YOU SEE MEDICAL
CENTERS ARE SELF SUSTAINING.
AND INCOME GENERATED BY THE UC
MEDICAL CENTERS PROVIDE
FINANCIAL TO SUPPORT SUPPORT TO
OUR HEALTH PROFESSIONAL SCHOOLS.
NO OTHER HOSPITAL WOULD FACE THE
KIND OF CONSTRAINT ACA FOURTEEN
WILL PLACE WHEN YOU SEE MEDICAL
CENTERS WHICH WILL PLACE THEM AT
A COMPETITIVE DISADVANTAGE AS
THEY COMPETE WITH OTHER HEALTH
SYSTEMS IN THEIR COMMUNITIES.
YOU SEE HOSPITAL'S OPERATING%
HIGHLY REGULATED AND HIGHLY
COMPETITIVE ENVIRONMENT FISCAL
DECISIONS LIKE A CA FOURTEEN CAN
AFFECT THE LONG RANGE
SUSTAINABILITY OF OUR MEDICAL
CENTERS.
AND WILL NEGATIVELY IMPACT OUR
ABILITY TO TRAIN THE NEXT
GENERATION OF DOCTORS AND OTHER
HEALTH CARE PROFESSIONALS.
CONSUMERS ARE DEMANDING LOWER
COSTS IN HEALTHCARE AND A CA
FOURTEEN WOULD ADD SUBSTANTIAL
COST TO HEALTHCARE.
AND FOR THESE REASONS WE OPPOSE
[inaudible]
AC.
FOURTEEN THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
IS THERE ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION YES HI KAREN CIRCUIT
SCENE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE IN
OPPOSITION [inaudible]
ANYONE ELSE.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
FINANCE NOTES AND YOU'RE CLOSE
TO SUPPORT IN CHRISTY'S ACOSTA
NEED TO BE CONSIDERED WITHIN THE
CONTEXT OF THE ANNUAL BUDGET
PROCESS.
ADDITIONALLY WE NOTE SECRETARY
OF STATE COSTA PRINT THIS
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENT IN THE
BACK THAT BALLOT PAMPHLET --
WHICH WILL DEPEND ALTERNATELY ON
THE LENGTH OF REQUIRED ELEMENTS
IN OVERALL SIZE OF THE BALLOT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
BRING IT BACK TO THE MEMBERS ARE
THERE ANY QUESTIONS.
MR COURT.
YES COMMENT SO I WORK FOR YOU
SEE FOR TWENTY SIX YEARS.
AND FOR THE FIRST FIFTEEN YEARS
EVERYBODY WHO WORKED AT THE LAB
WAS AN EMPLOYEE.
THEN THEY CONTRACTED OUT.
THE A CAFETERIA WORKERS.
SO INSTEAD OF HAVING PEOPLE WITH
PENSIONS ARE PEOPLE WITH
BENEFITS UP THEY WERE AT THE
MERCY.
OF A CONTRACTOR.
AND THEY LOS SENIORITY THAT LOST
RIGHTS THEY LOST -- SICK DAYS.
AND THAT WOULD YOU SEE YOU SEE
WAS ENTIRELY RUNNING THE LAB AT
THAT TIME.
THEN WHEN THAT WAS SUCCESSFUL --
THEY STARTED A WELL WE'LL LAW
CONTRACT OUT THE THE ARTISTS WHO
WORK FOR US PEOPLE WHO -- DO OUR
PRESENTATIONS AND THOSE PEOPLE
ARE THE PEOPLE WHO WORKED ON THE
LAB MAGAZINE WHICH I WAS AN
EDITOR WERE THEN CONTRACTED OUT --
THEN THEY CONTRACTED OUT
SCIENTISTS PEOPLE WHO WERE ON
FIVE YEAR CONTRACTS.
WHO?
WERE THE RIGHT PEOPLE FOR THE
JOB I'M SORRY YOU SEE.
YOU DON'T DO THIS WHEN IT'S
NECESSARY YOU DO THIS TO SAVE
MONEY.
I JUST -- WELL I'VE SAID ENOUGH
THANK YOU.
OKAY.
ANY ONE ELSE WITH A QUESTION IS
FRIEDMAN.
I JUST HAVE A QUESTION IS IT
ACCURATE THAT IF THIS RIGHT IF
THIS WERE TO PASS.
THAT THEY COULDN'T HIRE A TEMP
FROM WITHIN TEN DAYS.
THANK HIGHER PER DIEM WORKERS TO
FILL AND ESPECIALLY ON FMLA
ISSUES.
THERE'S A BROAD EXEMPTION FOR
PRETTY MARKERS.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS BY MEMBERS.
SEE NOW WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
I WOULD I JUST WANT TO KNOW --
BECAUSE WE STARTED SPIRALING
DOWN TO DOCTOR SOMEHOW WHEN
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT -- HEALTH
CENTERS THIS DOESN'T AFFECT
DOCTORS AND IT DOESN'T AFFECT
NURSES ASSIST SUPPORT STAFF THIS
IS -- THOSE PEOPLE WHO WHO.
MAKE PROFESSIONALS BE ABLE TO DO
THEIR WORK -- AND IT IS
SOMETHING THAT YOU KNOW YOU SEE
HAS BEEN ENGAGED IN THE RACE TO
THE BOTTOM FOR FAR TOO LONG AND
IT'S TIME -- TO I THINK THAT OR
AT LEAST IT SINCE WE CANNOT
PERMIT TO ASK THE VOTERS IF THEY
WANT -- CONTRACTORS WITH YOU SEE
TO HAVE EQUAL OPPORTUNITY TO
PEOPLE WHO ACTUALLY WORK THERE
THAT'S ALL WE'RE DOING HERE IS
SAYING.
THE VOTERS CAN MAKE THIS
DECISION -- AS AS IS CONSTRUCTED
IN OUR CONSTITUTION -- AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
AND I WANT TO THINK THE SIXTY
PLUS CO AUTHORS THAT WE HAVE ON
THIS BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- WITH THAT
WE HAD A MOTION BY MISTER QUIRK
AND SECOND BY MISS CARRILLO.
THAT BILL GETS OUT ON A AND B.
ROLL CALL WITH MR DEEP VOTING I
THANK YOU.
MISS MITCHELL I SEE YOU'RE OUT.
WITH ME DID YOU HAVE ANOTHER ONE
I DEAL IF IT'S OKAY MISTER
MARTINEZ STANDING RIGHT THERE IF
YOU DON'T MIND MISS MITCHELL.
THANK YOU THEY SHOULD BE QUICK
IT'S THE CLAIMS BILLS MISTER
PORTANTINO'S SB FOUR EIGHTEEN BY
NATURE OF THE IN CHAIR
PREPARATIONS COULD BE REQUIRED
TO CARRY THESE.
THANK YOU IT'S TWENTY SEVEN
POINT ONE MILLION FROM THE
GENERAL FUND TO THE TRAIN JOHN
FOR PAYMENT CLAIMS AGAINST THE
STATE -- WHICH HAVE BEEN PROVED
BY DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE AND
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY ABOUT.
GET WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ARE THERE ANY ANSWER QUESTIONS
IF ANYONE FROM THE AUDIENCE IN
SUPPORT ANYONE IN OPPOSITION
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
FINANCES IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH QUESTIONS OF
MEMBERS FOR THE AUTHOR.
SEEING NONE WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE.
THE BILL GETS OUT ON ANY WILL
CALL.
MISS MITCHELL OFF.
COME ON THAT.
CLOSE THIS OUT.
WELL SORT OF MORNING COLLEAGUES.
GOOD MORNING I'M HERE TO PRESENT
TO YOU SENATE BILL.
ONE EIGHT EIGHT THE CROWN ACT
WILL TO CREATE A RESPECTFUL AND
OPEN WORKPLACE FOR NATURAL HAIR.
SB ONE ABA CLARIFIES IN THE FAIR
EMPLOYMENT HOUSING ACT AND IN
EDUCATION CODE THAT THE
DEFINITION OF RACE IS INCLUSIVE
OF TRAITS HISTORICALLY
ASSOCIATED WITH RAFE INCLUDING
BUT NOT LIMITED TO HAIR TEXTURE.
AND PROTECTIVE HERE STYLES BY
DOING SO THE CROWN ACT PROTECTS
BLACK EMPLOYEES AND STUDENTS
FROM BEING FORCED TO CONFORM TO
A NON INCLUSIVE EURO CENTRIC
IDEA OF WHAT PROFESSIONAL LISTA
LOOKS LIKE.
AT THE EXPENSE OF MY PERSONAL
CHOICE OF HOW I CHOOSE TO WEAR
MY HAIR.
THIS BILL HAS A MINOR AND
OBSERVABLE THE SCHOOL IMPACT AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE MOVED THE BILL WITH THE
MACHINE BUT AFTER QUIRK A SECOND
BY MISS CARILLO -- IF WIN
ASSISTANCE PART.
I DO.
GOOD MORNING TO LIVE A CLOWN
BEHALF OF THE CROWN COALITION
WHICH INCLUDES OF THE COLOR OF
CHANGE THE WESTERN CENTER ON LAW
AND POVERTY IN THE NATIONAL
URBAN LEAGUE.
PROUD SPONSOR OF THE BILL IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU JUST GIVE OUR LOW IN
THE WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY SPONSORING SUPPORT.
ADDITIONAL SUPPORTERS.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS PAMELA GIVES
REPRESENTING THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION AND
WE SUPPORT THE BILL.
DO ANY SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
SCENE NINE DEPARTMENT FINANCE.
THE DEPARTMENT OF FAIR
EMPLOYMENT AND HOUSING ESTIMATES
THIS BILL HAVE A MINOR IN
OBSERVABLE FISCAL IMPACT THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE ESTIMATES
WILL HAVE A FISCAL IMPACT
REQUIRING ADDITIONAL RESOURCES
FROM THE LEGAL SERVICES
REVOLVING FUND.AND THE CALIFORNIA HUMAN
RESOURCES DEPARTMENT ESTIMATES
HIS BILL RESULT IN GENERAL FUND
COSTS THAT CANNOT BE ABSORBED
CURRENT.
THE PRIMARY SOURCES.
I SEE NO QUESTIONS WOULD YOU
LIKE CLOSE.
AS FOR IDOL THAT GETS OUT ON A
ROLL CALL WITH MR BIGELOW MR
PEROT NOT VOTING THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
WE HAVE TWO BILLS THAT WERE ON
CALL -- SB TWO TWENTY BY MISTER
HILL THAT GETS OUT ON A B. ROLL
CALL IN SB THIRTY BY MISTER
WEINER THAT GETS OUT WITH THE
REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING.
WITH THAT -- AS MEN SECRETARY
FEED READ THE BILLS THAT ARE
BEING MOVED TO THE SUSPENSE
WHILE.
H. R..
SEVENTEEN SB TWENTY TWO SB TWO
NINETY SIX AND SB THREE A ONE
THANK YOU IF THERE IS ANYBODY IN
THE AUDIENCE WHO WISHES TO SPEAK
ON WHEN THE BILLS THAT I HAD THE
AUTHORS WAY PRESENTATION AND THE
NEW DISPENSED FILE PLEASE COME
TO THE MICROPHONE.
NOW.
SEE NONE THAT CONCLUDES OUR OKAY
[inaudible]
OOPS.
I HAVE A MOTION BY MISTER MALONE
A SECOND BY MISTER CALDERON ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR AND THAT
GETS OUT -- PLEASE READ THE
CONSENT CALENDAR SORRY.
SB THIRTY SIX SB 614-013-22330
FOUR THREE SIXTY SIX THREE THREE
THREE NINETY NINE AND FOUR SIXTY
NINE THANK YOU GIVE ME A COUPLE
WEEKS OFF AND GET RUSTY -- THE
CONSENT COUNTER GETS OUT ON A
ROLL CALL AND THAT CONCLUDES OUR
MEETING OF THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE TODAY